outside of any personal experience how
do we know what we know about crime and
the methods employed to solve it
as long as there's been written language
historians have recorded landmark events
especially surrounding the lives and
deaths of some famous people
in some cases other people became famous
because something unusual either tragic
or extraordinary happened in their lives
and was written down for posterity in
our history books
this includes those who broke the laws
of society the unfortunate victims of
crime as well as those whose work helped
seek justice
i'm beth murray and i'm here to take you
on a journey through history by focusing
on some compelling forensic cases both
famous and not so famous including a few
of my own
i've been a practicing forensic
scientist specifically a forensic
anthropologist for nearly 30 years
i like to say i was forensic before it
was cool
but i'm also quite a history buff and i
love a great story thanks to my father
so this is a wonderful opportunity for
me to blend those interests and focus on
what i hope you'll agree are some
fascinating cases
together we'll re-examine some of the
world's most notorious crimes and at
times consider how they might be
investigated had they happened today
we'll also see how modern forensic
techniques have uncovered fresh or
unexplored evidence and used it to
re-analyze old cases shedding new light
on what we thought we knew
and in some lectures we'll look at more
recent forensic matters to see how far
we've come fighting crime
along the way you'll learn a little bit
about the history of forensic science
too
today much of our knowledge of crime
criminals their victims and forensics
comes from the media which of course is
a form of recorded history
so do you have any idea what's
considered by many to be the landmark
case for crime reporting
the forensic evidence and investigation
in this case created the first known
major media crime sensation which
started locally then spread across much
of the world
it's a forensic analysis that began in
the late 1880s and is still ongoing
today
this case has spawned hundreds of
theories countless publications and has
had some of forensic science's greatest
minds re-examine it
but despite all this effort we still
don't know the identity of the
perpetrator so he goes by the legendary
name of jack the ripper
although the exact number of victims is
not really known
most authorities agree that five women
killed between august 31st and november
9th of 1888
in the east london area known as white
chapel are confidently the work of one
serial killer
many sources also attribute a sixth
victim from earlier that august to jack
the ripper some theories raised the
number of victims to 11 women and still
other sources go even higher perhaps
including a seven-year-old boy
encompassing a larger group of attacks
that took place in the same general
vicinity between february 25th and
december 29th of 1888
but the earlier assaults during this
broader 10-month period seemed more
haphazard
and the victims were not killed as a
result most scholars believe those are
not connected but rather just reflect
the impoverished dangerous and
crime-ridden east end of london at the
time
it's also possible though that at least
some of those earlier attacks were the
more clumsy beginnings of a killing
spree that jack the ripper ultimately
mastered
now in addition to time what other
evidence has been used to connect some
of these crimes
the reason most agree five female
victims are definitively linked and why
some authorities insist others are
decidedly not the work of the same
killer is what forensic scientists call
modus operandi or simply the
perpetrator's mo
all these five women were prostitutes
who lived and worked in the slums of the
east end of london
so apparently part of the ripper's mo
was to prey upon women of the night
which is when all of these killings
occurred
but no semen was discovered in any of
these cases which not only further links
them but also suggests that rape was not
part of the mo
the murders are further connected by
increasing brutality showing an
escalation of sorts as time went on a
phenomenon seen in the careers of many
criminals
investigators look at these same facets
today when they suspect crimes might be
linked
victim choice weapon use level of
brutality escalation
connecting similarities like these is
really in a way just common sense
much of forensic science
analysis at least within the mind of the
investigator is similar to what our
brains do every day in countless
situations
compare data and recognize patterns
as an example let's look at the evidence
used to connect the white chapel
casualties in 1888.
the definitive rip ripper victims known
as the quote canonical 5 are the cases
agreed on by all accounts
all five were females whose poverty and
love of alcohol apparently led them to
prostitution
their ages varied somewhat but all were
young to middle aged
a range we'd assume typical for
prostitutes
all were caucasian but that could be
said of the entire neighborhood
the east end of london was rapidly
becoming crowded with immigrants from
ireland as well as russian jews which
resulted in economic downturn and social
tension as we'll see
but now let's get to the crime scenes
the first of the canonical five marianne
nichols also known as polly was
discovered on august 31st
she was lying on her back with her
skirts pulled up her throat was slashed
deeply twice all the way down to her
vertebrae
and her lower abdomen had been cut
several times
some of those belly wounds were so deep
they literally ripped open her body
cavity exposing her intestines
when a physician examined her remains at
the scene at around four o'clock in the
morning he considered body temperature
as we would do today
since her body and legs were still
somewhat warm compared to her cold hands
he concluded nichols was probably dead
for about half an hour
the body of the second victim annie
chapman was found around six o'clock on
the morning of september 8th
she also had two extremely deep cuts to
her throat which a physician later said
at the inquest had been made from left
to right
i assumed they thought this would
perhaps reveal whether the perpetrator
was behind the victim or in front of her
but that would also depend on whether he
was left or right-handed
now chapman's skirts had been raised and
this time not only was her belly cut
open but her intestines were pulled
outside her body and her uterus had been
removed and was missing this is what
forensic investigators call taking a
trophy
chapman's autopsy also showed bruises
that the doctor knew must have come from
a previous altercation
bruising doesn't happen at or after
death since once the heart stops beating
blood pressure no longer drives the
circulation that pushes blood out of
broken vessels and into tissues
dead skin lacks what's known as a vital
reaction
later witnesses described seeing annie
in a bar fight earlier in the week
substantiating the anti-mortem bruises
anyway the mo made it far more logical
to link this killing to the same vicious
perpetrator who had murdered marianne
nichols just a week before
not this not suspect that it was the
fallout from a bar room brawl
almost a month later on september 30th
the body of elizabeth stride was at
around one o'clock in the morning
but this case was different the victim
had only one cut to her neck her skirts
weren't raised and her belly wasn't
mutilated
so why did police connect her to these
other murders
several witnesses claimed to have seen
stride in the area between around 11 pm
and 12 45 on the same night she was
murdered
and in the company of a man
one witness told police the couple was
kissing in the recessed doorway of a
building and that he heard the man say
to stride you would say anything but
your prayers
another witness who claimed to have seen
stride about 12 30 a.m was a young
police constable
who said the man with her carried a
package about 18 inches long wrapped in
newspaper
so eyewitnesses are without fail a big
lead for investigators right
well not always
in this case there were numerous people
willing to say they saw a couple in the
area that evening or at least saw
elizabeth stride with a man but few of
them could agree on the appearance of
the guy they claimed to have seen
or the clothing he was wearing
an eyewitness testimony can be
notoriously unreliable
plus there's the well-known phenomenon
of people falsely reporting events to
get attention or to jump on the media
frenzy bandwagon around incidents like
this
but one eyewitness said he saw stride at
12 45 a.m in the same location where her
body was found in an altercation with a
man
the witness said the man had dark hair a
thin mustache was about five feet five
inches tall
broad-shouldered and around 30 years old
now this was fairly consistent with the
description of the man made by the
police constable
the onlooker thought he was watching a
domestic argument and he didn't want to
get involved
especially after the attacker took
notice of the witness so the bystander
decided to just keep on moving
we've all heard of cases in the news in
which people don't want to get involved
or maybe they only realize the gravity
of what they saw after they hear
later that they witnessed a crime
the discovery of elizabeth's body just
15 after this 15 minutes after this man
saw what he thought was a domestic
dispute
suggested the witness who was a
hungarian jew and had to be interviewed
through an interpreter
may not have only seen jack the ripper
but actually stumbled upon him
in the process of killing one of his
victims
authorities took the account of this
hungarian quite seriously for two main
reasons
first the witness came forward despite
significant anti-semitic tensions in the
area
second he saw what he described as an
altercation
including the woman's very low pitched
cry before the attacker noticed the
bystander causing the hungarian to rush
off
investigators already believed that the
ripper's mo was to strangle or slit his
victims throats cutting them twice so
deeply that their airway was cut
disabling them from screaming during the
rest of the attack
police theorized that the hungarian may
have stumbled upon the attacker as he
was just beginning to execute his
typical mo on stride
but once the ripper realized someone was
watching he ran off after only a single
cut to the victim's neck abandoning the
rest of his standard mutilation
an examination of strides body in the
courtyard where she lay
showed the cut in her neck was so deep
that there was a spray of blood
extending some distance from her body
today's blood spatter analysis wasn't
standard protocol at that time but my
read of that jet of blood sounds like a
major artery was cut
causing the force of the heart to send
the blood quite a distance away
an officer on the scene said the woman's
face was still warm corroborating her
recent death
within moments of the discovery of
strides body as people began shouting in
the streets that yet another murder had
taken place a crowd of nearly 30 people
had gathered around
this prompted an officer to tell them to
stand back
now he didn't seem as concerned about
them contaminating the crime scene with
their own trace evidence as we would
today
but rather he told them if they got
blood on their clothes they might be
suspect
in fact officers examined the hands and
clothes of onlookers for blood stains
just as might be done today
investigators took names and addresses
and even checked people's pockets before
allowing anyone to leave
stride's clothing was in place from head
to toe with one exception
the bow that had tied her scarf was a
skew as though the perpetrator had used
it to grab her from behind
a doctor at the scene estimated the time
of death at around 20 to 30 minutes
prior
based on the depth of the cut to the
victim's neck he said she would have
bled to death in a minute and a half or
so pretty sophisticated for 1888 isn't
it
keep in mind though that most common
people were familiar with slaughtering
animals and a standard method was
cutting the major vessels of the neck to
bleed them to death
now why else connect stride with the
ripper
what might a serial killer do if he's
built up a frenzy but then been thwarted
well about 45 minutes after the
discovery of strides remains the body of
katherine eddowes was found not too far
away
in a stroke of unbelievably bad fortune
eddows had been in jail that night for
being drunk and disorderly and that was
and she was released about one o'clock
that morning around the same time stride
was being murdered
if the ripper couldn't complete his full
ammo on stride he quickly did so on
edo's to satisfy himself
she had her throat slit twice her skirts
lifted her belly cut open from nearly
her navel to her rectum and portions of
her intestines removed and placed up on
her shoulder
this time in addition to most of her
uterus being cut out her left kidney was
also removed and taken as a trophy her
face was cut up too including one ear
investigators later found a piece of
cloth smeared with both blood and feces
not too far from the crime scene
the cloth turned out to be part of edo's
apron
that the killer had cut from her
clothing and then apparently used to
clean his knife and possibly his hands
had that happened today perhaps dna from
some somebody other than eddos might
have been found on that fabric
especially if the perpetrator had used
it to wipe off his hands
but when you consider how infrequently
people likely wash their clothing in
those days well the analysis would
certainly have been complicated
besides without a suspect whose dna
would be gathered for a comparison
sample
minimally though the victims could have
been definitively linked if the same dna
profile was found in each case even if
the owner of that dna was not known
another unusual aspect of the edo's case
was a message neatly written in chalk on
the wall in the busy marketplace right
next to where the piece of apron had
been discarded
it said quote the jews are the men that
will not be blamed for nothing end quote
the meaning of this message is still
open to debate and interpretation but it
echoed the anti-semitism that was
dividing the community with regard to
the murders
terror in society often stirs up wild
emotions including the desire to blame
and demonize some group or some person
and as we've seen throughout history we
most often point the finger at those who
are not like us
how would evidence like a chalk written
message on a building way building
entryway be captured
it should have been saved then as it
would be today using forensic
photography photography was well
established by then and there are many
images related to the ripper murders
available including morgue photos of
victims but unbelievably because of the
darkness of the early morning hour the
wait time for the arrival of
photographer and the fact that the shop
owners were beginning to open up their
market stalls the police decided instead
to just copy down the writing and then
obliterated the message at 5 30 in the
morning
they feared if crowds saw the message
there would be a riot against the jewish
community and more lives might be lost
well i can certainly understand their
anxiety destroying potential handwritten
evidence like that leaves me shaking my
head
many rippers scholars believe though
that the graffiti may have already been
there especially since some observers
said it was blurry
and it may have been a complete
coincidence that the piece of edo's
apron was dropped in the same location
either way there was heavy criticism of
the police decision to eradicate that
message
another interesting forensic aspect
related to this writing was the early
use of forensic linguistics that's the
study of language
based on the spelling and grammatical
errors the police commissioner felt
strongly the defeat the graffiti did not
come from a native english speaker
he wrote in his report quote the idiom
does not appear to be english french or
german but it might possibly be that of
an irishman speaking a foreign language
it seems to be the idiom of spain or
italy end quote
given the odd phrasing this makes
complete sense but it's interesting to
note the use of language to help profile
the suspect
the nonsensical nature of the wording
led authorities to two possible
conclusions if the killer actually wrote
it
jack the ripper was jewish and bragging
of it or the killer was trying to thwart
the investigation by blaming a jew
now what about other police profiling of
the likely killer
due to the anatomical knowledge some
ascribed to the mutilations and the
trophy removal
and the allegations that the ripper may
be a jew some began to suspect the
killer was a jewish slaughterhouse
worker so perhaps to help satisfy the
public the police rounded up the knives
of the local jewish slaughtermen to see
if any match the suspected weapon
a doctor concluded that none of them
seemed to be the murder weapon
so we see evidence of early attempts to
match a sharp tool with a wound
something common in forensics today
including in my own work
although typically far more reliable
when analyzing trauma to bone rather
than soft tissue
nearly two weeks after the night stride
and eddos were killed the chairman of
the white chapel vigilance committee got
a package containing half a kidney it
was preserved in wine and assumed to be
human
along with this was a note full of
spelling errors that explained the other
half had been eaten by the killer
we'll talk about notes attributed to the
ripper in a few minutes
but with regard to the kidney how could
forensic science establish this organ as
belonging to a human
well based on my many years of teaching
anatomy using both human and non-human
organs for dissection and microscopy i
can tell you that a pig kidney or that
of any similar sized animal is very like
that of a human
today's dna testing as well as much
faster antibody testing could allow
investigators to fairly quickly
determine the animal source
although i have no idea how pickling an
organ and wine might affect those tests
but the best they could do in 1888 was a
microscopic examination something
commonly done in autopsies today to look
for pathology but not to try to figure
out the species
a two doctors independently verified the
kidney was human
but based on the portion they had the
doctors were not specifically able to
match it to etto's body at her truncated
renal artery so they couldn't say for
certain it was her missing kidney but
they also couldn't prove it wasn't
now despite the rapid succession of four
victims in the month between august 31st
and september 30th
the last of the ripper five mary jane
kelly was not killed until november 9th
almost six weeks later
kelly's also the only one of the
canonical five murdered indoors
she lived in a multiple unit building
and two neighbors claimed to have heard
a woman cry out murder once at around
four o'clock
but said the building was always fairly
noisy
a man sent by the landlord to collect
some overdue rent that morning found
kelly's body around 10 45.
after knocking and then peering through
the window he was stunned to see kelly's
mutilated body on the bed and pieces of
flesh lying on a table near the window
he ran to get his boss then the landlord
sent his man on to the police station
this time the scene investigation seemed
much more thought out perhaps due to
criticism of the previous actions
police sent a telegram to scotland yard
to bring in the bloodhounds since the
crime scene hadn't been disturbed
the area was cordoned off to the public
no one was allowed to either enter or
leave and a doctor was called in
because the door was locked which is
curious to me but i don't know how the
door lock worked
the doctor looked through the window and
he immediately realized there was
nothing he could do for the victim so
they waited for the dogs
but for some reason the decision to use
the dogs was reversed
and at 1 20 in the afternoon police
broke down the door and began to examine
the murder scene
this time crime scene photos were taken
they're available and they're really
awful kelly's body was on the bed nude
with her legs splayed open her face had
been mutilated beyond recognition with
parts of her nose cheeks eyebrows and
ears removed
kelly's throat was cut to her spine her
abdomen completely eviscerated of its
organs which were found in various
places on the bed
her heart had been cut out and was never
recovered
pieces of skin and flesh had been
removed from her thighs down to the bone
as well as from her abdomen and her
breasts were excised
as i mentioned before some of her tissue
was piled on a table near the window
this shows the escalation of the
ripper's actions or maybe he just had
more time and privacy since he was
inside
investigators noticed the fireplace was
still warm and found a large quantity of
women's clothes that had been burned
perhaps to give the killer light by
which to work since there was only one
candle in the room
they searched for evidence of anything
unusual and found a man's pipe
but it ended up belonging to kelly's
boyfriend
police padlocked the door to a room to
protect the scene in case they wanted
later to re-examine things
and although they lack the technology we
have today
investigators did consider some of the
same things we do now
what's present and what's absent at the
scene what assumptions might we derive
from that evidence
later that day kelly's body was
autopsied there were so many cuts to the
victim's neck that investigators
couldn't establish the direction of the
weapon's path
because rigor mortis was setting in the
attending physicians estimated the time
of kelly's death at somewhere between
two and eight that morning
they believed it might have taken the
ripper perhaps two hours to do that much
damage to her body but unlike earlier
reports their conclusion was that the
killer did not have any anatomical
knowledge based on the haphazard way the
organs had been removed
they estimated the size of the blade
used at an inch wide and about six
inches long
though today it's known that estimates
of blade size from soft tissue wounds
are notoriously difficult and unreliable
the murder of mary kelly apparently
ended the killer's rampage at least in
the london white chapel area
no one knows to this day who he was or
why the murders ended did he die was he
incarcerated for something else did he
wind up in a mental institution did he
move away
despite thousands of books written on
the subject and countless articles
espousing different theories and
possible suspects
over 125 years of analysis
his identity is not known
why was the jack the ripper case such a
worldwide media sensation even back in
the 1880s i mean in addition to how
horrific it was
any idea why these murders are among the
first to prompt what investigators call
copycat killings
why this case ultimately included a
series of letters claiming to be from
the murderer
this brings us to another major theme i
hope you recognize throughout this
course and that's the continuous
interplay between science and society
for example how forensic advances in
both crimes and the technology used to
solve them are fairly directly
correlated with other changes in society
the simple reason this series of brutal
murders became the best known criminal
matter of its time
was the concurrent boom in newspaper
circulation in the second half of the
19th century
advances in printing and tax reform in
england allowed unprecedented low-cost
newspaper production and distribution
and since london was arguably the most
prominent of capital cities in the world
at the time
it had dozens of newspapers
the lancet times daily telegraph daily
news evening news standard star echo
lloyd's weekly east london observer east
london advertiser jewish chronicle
jewish standard a whole host of others
even one publication called the
illustrated police news which was an
early type of true crime magazine
in addition to the newspaper industry a
big reason word of the ripper's killings
went worldwide so quickly was that this
was also the time of advances in the
telegraph technology including
intercontinental communications
the 19th century also witnesses
witnessed many advances in photography
so in essence the ripper murders
coincided with the era when modern
journalism was born
so after the discovery of polynicles
mutilated body news of london's east end
crime wave spread quickly
newspapers across the globe picked up
that story and the related ones that
came with each killing
in fact the infamous name of the still
unknown killer was actually delivered to
the newspapers
it came in the form of a letter written
in red inc to london's central news
agency organization
on september 27th
that was between the second and third
murders among the canonical five
the letters author took credit for the
prostitute killings
saying he would cut off the ears of the
next victim and was signed jack the
ripper
later on october 1st a postcard in the
same red ink and handwriting was
delivered to the news agency about the
double event
alluding to the deaths of elizabeth
stride and kate eddows in the same night
even saying that quote number one
squealed a bit couldn't finish straight
off had not the time to get ears for
police
and if you remember although eddo's ears
were not removed one was definitely cut
but then
as now
many who have delved into the ripper
murders believe the letter and the
postcard were part of a hoax
most attribute them to someone in the
media a journalist who had inside
knowledge of the events and wanted to
sell newspapers and sell papers they did
in fact mary jane kelly's boyfriend told
police she regularly asked him to read
her the news of the killer from the
local papers little could either one
know that she would soon be front page
news as the ripper's final victim
[Music]
you